so on the new album girls night out you
work with the next generation of female
r b Stars which I love that is this on
purpose yes um
it was on purpose yeah I like it did you
just like love what you were hearing
like things you were hearing and you're
like let's just work with that person
too yeah it wasn't completely my idea it
was after I did versus uh my partner on
the album Rika she actually came up with
the idea that I should work with these
younger artists kind of like Excel but
the difference was we collaborated
together so instead of me writing
everything we wrote everything together
and we had one day to do it for each and
so every song that we did we we wrote
and we've recorded it that same day and
so it was kind of like
whatever happened happened yeah
absolutely well one of the groups you
wrote a lot for over the years was Boys
to Men which I love
this is this is my first record I ever
bought Motown Philly it was my first CD
I ever people are like what's the CD the
younger generation but whatever I'm
older um I I love this album and do you
remember the first time that you met
them I met them first time when I did
this song with them into the road just a
little song No One Knows yeah no it was
the first song because they they
adjusted they were really hot they did
Motown Philly and and so we wanted to do
um have them on the Boomerang soundtrack
yeah and so that was like the first
that's the song I wrote
um where I was trying to figure out what
kind of song to write for them because
you know they weren't doing that kind of
song exactly yet but they were from
Philly and they were and it just and
they said Philly Motown so I wanted to
give that old school kind of feel yeah
and um I love that you brought it back
to guitar like the acoustic thing well
that's actually
that was that ended up being later
because we went on the end of the road
we ended up doing that but we ended up
doing another song called water runs
that's what I mean that's what I mean
water register I thought that's where
you're going yeah yeah because I love
how it starts out so that went back you
know to that sixth grade kid again yeah
once again maybe you should write a
thank you letter to this lady
again and go to town like like I'm just
saying like that woman helped us out
tremendously with our own relationships
via your music it's funny because years
later I ended up you know
tracking her down
did you yeah because I wanted to talk to
her and see if I remembered everything
the same yeah you know and it was pretty
close and uh what did she say yeah no I
went into it like yeah
yeah I didn't want you like what what
did that conversation go like she said
that she didn't
uh she ultimately said you know I I
spent most of my life always thinking
about people that hurt me I never think
thought about the people that I may have
heard along the way she was sorry write
that song sir
that's a great lyric it was a great
lyric yeah and I said um I said to her
don't apologize it's because of you you
launched the kid that wrote a thousand
songs yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]